welcome back to have a session on
optimization okay can everyone hear me
okay all right so well I'm gonna talk
about two results which I think are
interesting so I wanted to review a
couple of facts about the cue AOA which
I'm doing because it's gonna help my
presentation so let's start with that
so what we're interested in here is
combinatorial optimization so we have
situations where you have n bits and M
clauses and typically we have a cost
function C of Z which is a sum over
clauses we have AB clauses and each of
these little clause functions it's a 1
if the clause is satisfied and it's 0 if
it is not so this is the general
framework for combinatorial optimization
i'm just i know people know this but i'm
just trying to get language down so but
the goal in combinatorial optimization
is to make that to find the maximum of
that function and of course that's the
mother of all np-complete problems so
that's a very ambitious goal to find the
efficient algorithm for that so what
we're gonna do be interested in it
something a little less ambitious which
is finding a good approximation so that
means we want to find have an algorithm
that outputs the strings such that C of
Z over C max is big and we'll have to
talk about what that means and that's
called approximate optimization please
interrupt me because it says you know so
the quantum algorithm which we're gonna
use here it has two basic ingredients
it's an alternation of unitary
operations the first unitary which I'm
going to define depends on the cost
function and it's the exponential
depending on a parameter gamma of the
cost function and note that since the
cost function is the sum of commuting
terms
this can be written as a product of over
the clauses of evening the - I gamma C a
my site gamma C sub alpha now the other
operator now that doesn't change the bit
strings it just puts phases on them so
we have another operator which actually
moves the bits around like sometimes we
call it like the driver so consider B
which is the sum of the Sigma axes and
then the unitary which we have here is
the exponential of this and that's just
a rotation around the X direction by an
angle beta of all the qubits and
typically we're not always we start in
the uniform superposition over all
strings and note that these are all easy
to construct operators and you can
imagine putting this on hardware now for
any integer P P s would be has become
for us the definition sort of the depth
of the algorithm I wanted to find 2
Peter so there are P gammas and P betas
and then we're gonna make a state which
is start with the initial state then act
with this operator that depends on the
cost function with angle gamma 1 their
angles because things are all integer
valued so the cost function is integer
value then the Sigma axis or having two
dragon values so it's enough to think of
these as angles and then we apply the B
operator then we have this alternation
so there are a total of 2p applications
of these unit ares the circuit depth is
the most MP plus p that's not so
important for because we're not really
worrying about implementation here but
now the we want to do is we want to take
this quantum state which depends on two
people rameters and attempt to make the
cost function big so the goal is to opt
to make the cost function big in the
quantum state so let me we define this
FP that depends on the depth of gamma
Bader's dysfunction and MP is the
maximum of or it's easy to say that the
maximum can only increase as you
increase the depth because at if you go
up in pay you're doing a relaxed
optimization reule
to the previous level so this can only
increase and actually can show that as P
goes to infinity the limit of MP is C
max but that's not particularly useful
to me because this really requires P to
grow like exponentially an N and I'm not
really interested in that it's just a
math fact of not great relevance that
you know you can get to the infinite
value now the quantum out with angle
search one of the ways you might
approach this is to start with fixed
angles gamma beta use the quantum
computer to make the state measure to
get a string Z and up compute C of C
repeat with same angles to get a good
estimate of the previous object and then
repeat with new angles to try to go
uphill
now that's what people talk about when
they talk about variational quantum
algorithms where you use the quantum
computer to make calls to a function but
you have some kind of outer loop that
you use to go up and so we might imagine
running the Q AOA in this mode or we
might not depends on what we want to do
but for fixed P we can actually
classically pre-process and determine
the best angles in advance and I want to
give you the argument for that let's
look at max cut on three regular graphs
so max cutters I think we all know what
it is the cost function for max cut if
you have an edge JK is a half minus CJ
ZK you see this thing is a zero if these
two things agree but it's a 1 in other
words it's happy if they disagree that's
the cost function for max cut and and if
you look at P equals one let's look at
the contribution from one edge so this
is some 1/3 regular graph I have an edge
JK so since the cost function is the sum
if I look at what I get I have the
expectation in the state s of this thing
with JK this is just what it is
at the lowest dimension and s is the
product is a product state because it's
a product of eigenstates in the X of
spins pointing in the X direction
now let's look at the innermost
conjugation where we conjugate JK by the
beta's B's well that just rotates the
qubits but it doesn't change the
locality and but now when I conjugate by
e to the I gamma C in other words this
this little piece here that pushes the
operator that's in the middle here
beyond the two qubits I'm looking at but
the only thing it can involve all the
bits connected to J and K in the graph
that's all you see so you have this edge
and then you can see the things in the
graph but since I'm looking at a three
regular graph there are only three sub
graph possibilities the sort of obvious
one is J is connected to two friends K
is connected to do friends and none of
these are friends of these but the other
possibility is I have one triangle or
two triangles but there are the only
three possibilities and what that means
is that each sub graph type gives a
special function of gamma and beta which
does not depend on n RM and that means
that these can be evaluated on a
classical computer looking at four or
five or six qubit subsystems because
this is six five four cubits and given
that for if I know the number of sub
graph types in the graph which I can
count then I can evaluate this function
and optimize that and using this we were
able to show a p equals one the Q AOA
will produce a cut that is at least
point six nine to four times the optimal
cut and that we could prove for all
instances of three regular max cut so
the thing that we accomplished there was
we got a worst-case performance
guarantee by analyzing the algorithm
okay we comfy so now I want to change it
and now not look at a worst-case
performance but look at the Q AOA on
typical graphs so I want to imagine that
I'm generating graph
by some distribution so for example I
might have I might be sampling uniformly
three regular graphs or I might include
each edge with a probability three over
N minus one if you do that the average
degree is three or I might include ya or
I might include each edge with a
probability D over n minus 1 that means
the average greaves D whatever I have a
distribution and I'm not looking at
worst-case but I'm looking at typical
now what we're gonna demonstrate now is
that if you look at the expected value
of the cost function in the state gamma
beta that for typical instances this
function is the same for all the
instances so this thing concentrates and
that's sort of interesting but up to
Corrections so this is I wrote a paper
on this with Fernando Michael salmon
Hartmut and let me argue why that is the
case this concentration it's very useful
to know this consider P equals 1 let's
go back to my max cut example let's
imagine I've uniformly generated them in
some manner so for large n you'll the
fraction of subgraph types will
concentrate because if I have a giant
graph and I count the number of each sub
graph type it's gonna be a fixed
fraction because the graph is giant and
I've distributed uniformly in fact it's
all going to be these because if you
have a giant graph it doesn't have
little triangles but that's so it
doesn't matter in principle just it's
all these three types but since I know
the sub graph types
this is instance independent ok so that
just proved that for you know P equals 1
on three regular graphs it concentrates
it's the same for every big three
regular graph that I generated ok now
this what yeah
well I mean that I let's say yeah let's
say that is the one ensemble right I
could have an ensemble of all three
regular graphs I pick each one with
equal probability that's an example yeah
mm-hmm that's a well-defined ensemble
yeah
okay so now but I thought we just proved
the concentration and you see this proof
will generalize to an higher P as long
as P is small enough that I have
sub-graphs which I can analyze which
you're not covering the whole graph so
this just proved concentration for small
P now we come for you with that I mean
it'll work at P is two three four didn't
just have bigger sub graph times okay
but now I want to show you something
that's interesting which we discovered
numerically which is I'm gonna look at
20 vertex three regular graphs so three
regular graphing 20 vertex has 30 edges
and a teacher that might look at 25
samples but then what I do is we did is
we we go to P let's say P equals three
and we let me just normalize this for
you
if you have a graph with 30 edges the
typical cut will have it will will be 15
that's just the way it works out it's
half of 30 so so 15 is kind of the
number to think about is what you would
get randomly so but I can choose the
parameters so that I'm getting a low
value of the cost function and what we
find is that if I go to P equals 4 and I
find some fairly low value because this
is like 3.9 and we tossed 25 samples the
standard deviation is this it really
does concentrate in other words I've
chosen the angles to make the cost
function small and it concentrates over
the samples and if I put random angles
well then everything is near 15 and if I
pick good angles meaning high values
these only improve as you increase the
depth I also find concentration so this
is sure
numerically that it works but no what
happens here with P equals seven you see
if I have a sub graph at if I'm on a
three regular graph and I have a sub
graph with that the little tree I showed
you had six things coming at the six
nodes but if I go to P equals two my
next graph that the size of it is 14 and
if I go to P equals three the next size
is 30 and if I go to P equals four it's
62 so by the time I'm at P equals four
my sub graphs are covering the whole
graph so this is already big P from the
sides I'm working at and so by the time
I'm at seven I've multiple covered the
graph so there are no sub graphs anymore
so the sub graph argument went away but
the result is still there so that's sort
of interesting okay because I lost my
argument but I still have the same
result so why can that be well consider
F gamma beta it's a sum over clauses and
imagine that there is a distribution
over instances and think of C alpha as a
random variable now if the if these are
independent then the sum will
concentrate by the law of large numbers
it doesn't depend on n or anything it's
just the pence on the number of samples
right if you want to estimate you know
if you have a big jar with a trillion
jelly beans and you want to estimate the
number of red ones it only depends on
the number of samples doesn't depends on
how many things are in the jaw and so
here this will yes if these are
independent then this will concentrate
by the law of large numbers does that
make sense so now the question is do
they look in the pendant and so we
tested that we actually went to the
computer and measured correlation
coefficients between difference the
Alpha and random instances and they were
always very small the correlation
coefficients to a statistician the value
point
Oh Forrest tiny for correlations they
think of big correlations when that
number is too close to one so they're
uncorrelated so we don't have a proof
that this works for large P but the
numeric suggests that our intuition is
correct and that if you go to higher bit
number it's hard to believe the
correlations will increase so anyway
that's the statement but this has
certain so that why is it doing that
okay come on computer Oh No
what am i doing I'm so sorry on the
other screen
oh there it is it's just has a funny
color okay who cares right all right so
so a new strategy for random instances
so what you could do is pick one
instance and work hard to get good
angles and maybe that requires many
calls to the quantum computer but then
you can use these angles for other
instances so it gets rid of the outer
loop because it says once you've found
good angles for one instance you can use
them for all of them and that's very
helpful
in terms of the approach to this and
this works because you saw my numerix
does that make sense once you know that
once you know that the parameters for
one instance the best parameters are the
same the same for the next instance then
you don't have to search again and of
course it doesn't produce the string you
still need the quantum computer to make
the string god you know this landscape
is not that gnarly it just has you know
one local minute what has I usually when
numerically I search for the global
minimum there's yeah it's just one
global minimum
well maximum excuse me with respective
well I think my argument is just didn't
care about my argument is for any
distribution on any kind of sets of
graphs yeah I think these arguments are
way more general than the particular
that I've outlined there's nothing to do
with that
so that's kind of okay so now well I
want to go to my next thing sherry do
Patrick but another finding we had is
that if you toss a random graph at ten
bits at P equals eight and you get good
angles then you know people if you do it
numerically at ten bits P equals eight
you get a very good approximation ratio
0.984 but you can use those same 16
angles at 24 bits and you get a also a
very good approximation ratio so it also
says that if you find good angles on a
random graph at low n and then you can
use that at a high-end and it still
works
which is very helpful but I don't know
why that's the case at high P a low P
it's obvious but high P I do not have I
don't have an argument for why that
works but I just know it does okay so
maybe I'll skip this but this this can
result in all kinds of nice strategies
for running the Q AOA in which you don't
have to do outer loop optimization now
okay there any questions about that cuz
I'm going to change the topic
no I didn't say pickles 20 I said I'm
sorry go ahead no no if I said going to
hire peer meant to say higher n I
misspoke then if I said that yeah maybe
I misspoke yes no that's fine it's
probably me so I mean I was at P equals
I think I was at P equals 8 and it went
from 10 to 24 okay
I kept the same angle you know this is
not the worse case no but I know I mean
I'm just talking about typical cases I
don't have a worst case result no
because that's determined by pink the
depth of the circuit no the circuit
depth is the same no okay yeah okay yes
I do observe that sometimes but you know
it's very hard if you're a P equals 2
and n is gigantic to think of it as an
adiabatic algorithm but it is a fact and
I will talk about this more in the
Sherrington go Patrick that very often
you do see if you plot the angles that
the betas are decreasing and the gammas
are increasing kind of looks adiabatic
ish yes okay
it still works have you I mean compared
that to just directly optimizing well no
but then oh no but when I go to the
larger graph I can use that as a
starting point for further optimization
so that's what I didn't get into the
strategies from running the computer but
no but I suppose I tell you I can get at
good angles at you know 10 I have P
equals 8 there are 16 angles I get some
good angles at 10 bits then I go to 24
and I just showed you the value using
those angles but that can be improved
because that could be the start of a
local search I don't know cuz I can't
show that that's true it's very hard for
me to estimate something I can't show is
true I can't I can't show it's true I
just know it's true so let's be a
tougher position ok I'm gonna go for
another I'm gonna go a couple minutes
over because I think I have a whole
other topic but I'll try to do it fast
ok thank you cuz yeah the Dutchman would
take my head off all right so I would
like to talk change the topic and we're
gonna talk about a very fascinating
model it's called the Sherrington core
Patrick model this model was introduced
in the 70s and the way it works is you
have n bits and the variables though now
zas which take the value plus or minus 1
and have a cost function this is a
complete graph so it's 1 over root and
the sum on a less than b jb za ZB with
the only thing I really care about is
that the mean of J a B is 0 and the
variance of J a B is 1 it could be any
distribution with that property and this
thing is called the Sherrington
Kirkpatrick model and it was developed
in the 70s and actually I believe
simulated annealing was designed to salt
to find to work on this particular model
but as n goes to infinity you can show
that the maximum of C divided by n
there's 0.763 dot dot dot dot dot now
this is a famous result due to Giorgio
Parisi in the 70s which introduced all
these concepts like replica symmetry
breaking but if you actually look at
what he did
it looks like voodoo I mean it's really
strange math and no one could understand
that but then this French mathematician
Tala Grande proved it was all rigorously
correct and so this is like the
prototypical spin glass model where we
know what the best configuration is all
right and there's this whole world
centered around this so that's why it's
a good thing to look at okay and this is
calculated to 14 decimals no just tells
you the energy doesn't give you the
configuration what I'm after now is the
finding configurations exactly tells you
the energy not the configuration right
so now I want to look at the P equals 1q
AOA and here what I'm gonna do is this
is what it looks like I want the cost
function over end because the way I've
normalized things the energy scales
within so here I I'm gonna in this thing
I'm gonna insert complete sets a
complete set of Z 1 Z 2 Z 3 so this is C
of Z 1 this is the matrix element
between Z 1 and Z 2 C of Z 2 etc so I'm
just writing it out but C of Z is 1 over
root n and the sum of a less than B of
jbz a B but you know if I if I is small
then the expected value of J of e to the
I Phi J is 1 minus Phi squared over 2
and the expected value of J of e to the
I Phi J J is I Phi that just comes from
the fact that the mean is 0 and the
variance is 1 and Phi is small but my
Phi is going to be small because I'm
gonna average over the J's but I have a
1 over root N in front because of the
way I set it up so I have a small Phi
and that is going to allow me to
actually
average over the Jays now the reason I'm
keen on this so let me tell you the
result then I'll say why I like it is
because upstairs I have this with JB
downstairs I have this and I can just
use the fact that I know how to average
to do the averaging a verge over
instances and then if I average over
instances in others take the expected
value over J of gamma beta C over in
gamma beta take the limit as n goes to
infinity I get this formula so it can
calculate it as n goes to infinity by
hand by hand this is just calculated and
then you can optimize it and at gamma
equals 1/2 and beta equals PI over 8 to
get 0.303
which is you know halfway to parisi
almost now the reason that this is
something a little bit John Brett
pleased with this is because you see if
you if you look at the Parisi thing
usually what people do is they you know
they want to find that they have a cost
function so they look at e to the minus
beta times the cost function and they
want to take beta to be small and they
take you know the trace of this and what
you might attempt to do is this depends
on configurations J so you might want to
take the expected value with respect to
J that gives the wrong answer
that's what Cherrington cap a trick did
what you have to do is first take the
log and then take the expected value and
that's what makes this that's what's
hard this is getting the order of the
log and the averaging right and so in
the so the whole point of parisi is he
figured out how to take the expected
value of the log but I don't take a log
I just do it directly and that's what
allows me to proceed so any way we could
do that and then beyond that we can for
any fixed P we have an iterative
procedure to evaluate the limit as n
goes to infinity of this quantity we
actually can do this for any P but the
procedure we have involves a numerical
evaluation
and and it gets hot and the time for the
numerical evaluation goes like 16 to the
P but we were able to carry it out to P
equals 8 and we got up to 0.607 so we
keep doing better and better so this so
this is I mean we have I think it's a
nice result because we can show that as
n goes to infinity I can guarantee you
this performance for a very shallow
depth P is not growing with n it's you
know 8 and I'm getting as n goes to
infinity a nice result not only that but
we can prove the next thing which is a
concentration in other words we can
prove that as the limit as n goes to
infinity the expected value of the
square is the square of the expected
value and what that means is that that
proves landscape independence because
that proves this is 4 over different
instances this proves that every inch
this says that the variance over
instances of the expected value of the
cost function is going to 0 as n goes to
infinity so that means that we proved
for this model the landscape
independence that I was referring to
before as n goes to infinity but I can
also show something else that as n goes
to infinity for typical instance every
string you measure will have that value
as well so it is it is it concentrates
both over the instances and then it
concentrates over the measurements ok
which is it's gonna nice to know that
so then so I mean this is really what I
want to show and I'm working quite hard
on it and failing I want to show the
four n goes to infinity and then P goes
to infinity we achieved the parisi value
we haven't done that yet we just see it
getting better but it's does it's
technically complicated to show that and
then I mean now though we want to apply
these to EC this idea of tossing random
instances and analyzing the QA Oh a by
averaging is a new tool that allows us
to get formulas that we were
inaccessible when we were talking about
worst case instances so I mean I'd like
to know I would like to apply our
techniques to other problems where
instances is drawn from whatever
distribution I don't know
I mean I I tend to look it like I'm
looking now at independence at on three
regular graphs oh that's the end of my
talk okay perfect thank you question and
after the three talks that we'll be
breaking then all the speakers will be
back for a discussion session so we have
more time for I'm not sure I think I
think it's in the 20s or 30s you'll see
oh oh oh no no wait a second
I'm trying to remember know inside my
paper we show results fan of twenty six
and you know it all works very well
no actually that's my I wish I knew that
because if I knew exactly that I would
be able to prove that I hit the Parisi
value so that's what I saw in fact all I
really need to prove is that it's
monotone in an I can't prove that if I
can prove it's monotone in an I will be
able to prove we go to the Parisi value
so I don't have complete control over
finite and affects I don't accept that P
equals 1 we're all peoples one I can
analyze everything we have the exact
formulas for all n but beyond that I
think we also yeah we also have the
exact formulas I think for P equals 2
but you know for big P I don't have 4
I don't have the 1 over N Corrections
that answers your question I'm trying I
want them
okay so let's think okay thank you